[Musik]
die hand des screens liebe hörerinnen
und hörer willkommen zu einer neuen
folge mit der nummer 49 und dem titel
ethik und moral in games und für dieses
spannende große und breite thema haben
wir uns verstärkung geholt und begrüßen
dafür unseren gast den philosophen jörg
noller hallo hallo viel dafür die
einladung und außerdem dabei die jessica
hay
schön dass ihr beide da seid schön ganz
besonders dass du auch da bist dass der
zeit genommen hast york wir freuen uns
sehr du hast einen ein unfassbar
interessanten hintergrund aus der
philosophie bis hin zur arbeit mit
digitalen medien und der beschäftigung
mit games was dich halt absolut
auszeichnet heute hier darüber zu
sprechen denn moral und ethik sind
natürlich auch themen die ja würde ich
sagen ich ganz kino ihnen der
philosophie verhandelt werden und
studiert hast du philosophie
literaturwissenschaft geschichte und
theologie eine ganze menge und bis dann
sozusagen irgendwann hat dann wirklich
geführt ans institut für wissensmedien
in tübingen und du arbeitest
mittlerweile eben auch zu themen von
digitalen medien aber nicht überlebt da
gerne einmal an dich bevor wir so
richtig in das thema der philosophie und
der ethik einsteigen wie bist du
eigentlich diesen weg gegangen von der
philosophie und welche bedeutung hat
dann jetzt die ethik eigentlich für
games ja vielen dank für die vorstellung
mich hat schon immer das digitale
interessiert ich würde mich schon als
einen halben die genetik bezeichnen also
in den 90ern habe ich schon die ganze
entwicklung der computer von 486 dann
auf pentium und dann amd dieses duell
mit verfolgt auch wirklich praktisch
natürlich immer mit blick auf die
computerspiele da lief noch nicht jedes
spiele man musste da schon mal schrauben
ein bisschen patches oder aufrüsten also
diese ganze kultur kenne ich sehr gut
auch die ganzen entwicklung dieser neuen
spiele von denen es jetzt immer noch
sequels gibt
hab ich wirklich mitbekommen auch sehr
intensiv gespielt zum thema
digitalisierung oder ich spreche
eigentlich nur von digitalität ich kann
da auch später noch ein bisschen genauer
eingehen was ich den unterschied halte
zwischen digitalisierung digitalität bin
ich einige über die lehre gekommen also
ich habe dann irgendwann an der
universität münchen die dii gehabt mal
des internet blogs wikis auch apps mit
einzubeziehen die lehre und habe dann
seid ihr nicht mehr aufgehört und so hat
sich das eine aus dem anderen entwickelt
anfangs hatte ich nur didaktisch
pädagogisches interesse und mit der zeit
hat sich da ein wirkliches theoretisches
interesse daraus entwickelt also die
frage was sind eigentlich computer
spiele da kommen ja heute noch genauer
darauf zu sprechen sind es bloß
erzählungen sind es bloße simulationen
oder die frage was ist eigentlich
virtuelle realität solche theoretischen
fragen sind dann im ausgang von meiner
didaktischen beschäftigung mit den neuen
medien entstanden
ja vielen dank und das sind alles total
wichtige fragen bewerben glaube ich
heute dazu kommen dass wir immer mal
wieder so auf grundsätzliche fragen und
begriffe stoßen die wir so ein bisschen
erklären müssen also das ist würde ich
als aus einer außenperspektive behaupten
eine ganz philosophisch praxis sich am
begriff so abzuarbeiten das werden wir
heute vielleicht ein bisschen mit in den
podcast nehmen bin aber auch ganz
gespannt darauf das thema ethik und
moral das ist ja etwas also das ist
etwas dass unser handeln
leitet sozusagen eigentlich in der oder
leiten kann in unserer echten welt erst
mal dann sprechen wir davon ist etwas
ein ethisches handeln oder ein ethisches
handeln
dinge die man vielleicht tun soll oder
nicht tun soll werden darunter gefasst
man soll vielleicht nicht töten man
sollte vielleicht nicht lügen das sind
jetzt ethische ansprüche die darin
formuliert werden jetzt ist es aber so
dass spiele jetzt erstmal ja nicht in
unsere echten welt stattfinden aber die
nehmen sich durchaus mal solche
szenarien zur hand die eigentlich auch
ethische sind wir kennen das irgendwie
na also
da gibt es zb dann bei star wars the
force unleashed kann man dann den den
hellen fahrt dass jede einschlagen oder
sole den dunklen pfad einschlagen ganz
oft gibt es in star wars spielen dann
diese unterscheidung das ist ja ein
mythos auch eine ganz große
gegenüberstellung quasi von gut und böse
ja aber jessica um dich auch einmal hier
in unser podcast gespräch mit
reinzuholen woran denkst du denn
eigentlich als erstes bei solchen ethik
und moral geschichten in spielen
mir ist als ich mich ich hätte noch
einmal mit diesem thema so ein bisschen
beschäftigt habe wieder eingefallen dass
ich ganz zu meiner beginnzeit dessen
dass ich mich mit psychologie und
spielen in diese kombination auseinander
gesetzt habe habe ich mal auf meinem
damals noch existierenden blog einen
artikel dazu geschrieben zum bösen in
games also was was bewegt uns dazu ich
habe das hauptsächlich auf die sims
bezogen dass wir unsere sind manchmal so
schlecht behandeln also das ist auch so
ein bisschen sonne rabbit hole wenn man
das mal auf youtube ein gibt und danach
sucht nach torture chambers für sims
finden sich allerlei abstruse videos und
die menschen über treffen sich
eigentlich darin irgendwelche
folterkeller und andere süßigkeiten für
ihre sims irgendwie zusammen zu bauen
und da habe ich mich gefragt was ist das
eigentlich warum warum machen wir so was
so was würden wir im leben
höchstwahrscheinlich hoffentlich bitte
nicht tun warum ist es denn endspielen
so interessant und warum geben uns viele
spiele eben auch genau die möglichkeit
videos jetzt gerade auch schon auf
gemacht hast du verschiedene pfade
einzuschlagen also das ist ja was was
auch mit technischem fortschritt immer
mehr einzug hält dass wir solche
branding mary tipps haben wo wir ganz
verschiedene pfade einschlagen können
und uns unterschiedlichen spielen ja
ausdrücken könne und dinge tun oder
dinge nicht tun können und dass dann
eben auch verschiedene ergebnisse
produziert etwas was schon ganz breit
aufgemacht ich denke da immer schon an
diese auswahl systeme da wirklich diesen
knopf links den schalter um soll die
atombombe auf dieses dörfchen in fallout
3 fallen zb eine ganz berühmte
entscheidung und
anekdote möchte ich einmal dazu dazu
mitbringen wollte schon die sims erwähnt
hast wir haben auf twitter die frage
gestellt an unsere follower erinnern wie
ist das bei euch was ist das böseste was
ihr getan habt und die hälfte hat
einfach nur geantwortet mit ich habe die
sims gespielt
das war schon impliziert ja was sagst du
dazu wenn die leute die torture chambers
in spa ich finde es ein ganz
interessantes phänomen das war mir
selbst jetzt noch gar nicht bewusst muss
ich gleich mal googeln oder auf youtube
suchen vielen dank jessica für diesen
hinweis ist ein grand okay also ich
finde es sehr interessant weil man
einfach hier sieht spiele erlauben uns
auch entscheidungen zu fällen in
verschiedenen alternativen ja es wurde
schon gesagt hellweg dunkler weg es geht
natürlich zurück bis in die antike
herkules am scheideweg gewinner den
tugendhaften weg oder den tugendhaften
weg beschreiten und dasselbe vollzieht
sich jetzt auch im medium der
computerspiele natürlich können wir dann
immer sagen es ist ja nur eine
simulation hat diesen menschen in sin
city oder wo auch immer den passiert ja
wirklich gar nichts mehr aber dennoch
ist es eine entscheidung die wir
vollziehen und da stehen bestimmte
motive und gründe dahinter also es hängt
entscheidend davon ab wie wir das jetzt
moralisch bewerten wie wir
computerspiele bewähren davon hängt dann
ab wie wir auch mit diesen menschen in
simcity umgehen city liegt ja auch schon
so ein bisschen es ist nur eine
simulation hier wird also nur eine stadt
simuliert und dementsprechend sind
unsere handlung auch bloße simulierte
handlung aber dennoch ist es ja eine
handlung die wir vollziehen haben wir
tun ja was wir überlegen uns sehr was
und deswegen ist die sache nicht so
trivial und nicht so einfach abzutun
dass man einfach nur sagt es ist ja bloß
eine simulation oder eine fiktion als er
jedenfalls was worauf es mir ankommt ist
zu sagen hier wird unsere fantasie ganz
art angeregt hier finden verschiedene
szenarien stadt verschiedene möglichkeit
verschiedene räume
wir öffnen die wir auch wieder schließen
können ist also ein hochgradig
faszinierendes phänomen auch aus
philosophischer perspektive
du hast jetzt schon gesagt wir treffen
entscheidungen in spielen das bedeutet
ja wir sind da irgendwie handelnde event
wird vielleicht in wenn wir an auf
andere medien schauen etwas stärker
vielleicht rezipieren de sind eigentlich
wir schauen einen film
das ist erstmal passiv das passiert
natürlich auch aktive prozesse im kopf
im innern aber dennoch sind wir dort
keine handelnden erstmal in vielen
anderen medien und jetzt auf einmal ist
es irgendwie anders ich habe dazu bei
jochen venus einmal nachgelesen er nimmt
er nennt es in spielen erlebtes handeln
das fand ich sehr interessant ich bin
mir sicher dass du den den aufsatz dort
auch kennst im grunde geht es darum dass
wir eigentlich
gleichzeitig eine figur beobachten die
etwas tut und im selben moment diese
figur aber auch irgendwie sind das
selber des handelnden subjekt auch sind
und dass das die ganze zeit irgendwie
gleichzeitig passiert was bedeutet das
eigentlich
das ist ein spannendes phänomen auch
guter begriff ich denke hier kann man
noch weiter unterscheiden welche
perspektive wir selbst im spiel
einnehmen wenn wir von avataren reden
gibt es ja verschiedene perspektiven die
wir auf diese avatare werfen können es
gibt die völkersen prospective da sehen
wir sie dann von hinten da finden dann
dieses phänomen stadt was du geschrieben
hast oder wenn wir
sidescroller spielen jump n run spiele
je nachdem auf welcher ebene sich diese
identifikation bezieht ich denke jetzt
aber vor allem an 3d 3d perspektive da
wo wir also selbst im archiv in eine ich
perspektive hineingezogen werden und
hier ist dann ganz interessantes
phänomen dass wir uns hier eigentlich
gar nicht mehr wirklich identifizieren
müssen mit dieser person die wir spielen
sie dann sind wir selbst das spiel wir
nehmen es aus seiner ich perspektive
wahr weshalb ich auch 3d shootern da
gibt es ein gutes buch zum selben titel
von stephan günzel eine ganz besondere
rolle zugestehen würde es muss jetzt
nicht nur ein shooter sein es kann auch
wirklich in adventures sein oder sandbox
spiel was einfach aus diese ich
perspektive stattfindet das scheint mir
ein ganz interessantes phänomen zu sein
und noch ein anderer punkt du hattest
erwähnt computerspiele sind nicht nur
passive konsum mädchen das scheint mir
ganz wichtig seien häufig werden
computerspiele nur auf dieses mediale
konsum denken reduziert das würde in
meinen augen diesem phänomen nicht
gerecht computerspiele sind auch
unterschieden von
romanen wo ja auch eine gewisse
fiktionalität eine rolle spielt aber
anders als in filmen die du schon
erwähnt hatte dass wir uns das ganze
geschehen imaginieren müssen es steht
zwar da gedruckt oder wie auch immer wir
müssen es gewissermaßen vor unserem
eigenen geistigen auge erschaffen durch
viel fantasie und kreativität das
computerspiel geht in meinen augen noch
einen schritt weiter hier müssen wir uns
nämlich auch mal einiges erschaffen wir
können aber selbst auch die
protagonisten seien im roman wird uns
der protagonist die protagonistin
vorgegeben im spiel können wir selbst
protagonistin sein und das macht das
computerspiel so faszinierend eben auch
aus ethischer perspektive
ich würde da gerne an der stelle ohne
jetzt zu tief ins detail zu gehen weil
auch das ein rabbi toll wäre wenn wir
uns dem jetzt wirklich widmen würden
aber ich habe in dem buch von daniel
martin feige philosophie des
computerspiels ein bisschen gelesen und
da gibt es einen aufsatz von fabian
börchers der zum handeln schreibt und
der macht da finde ich eine sehr
interessante da ich von philosophie
absolut keine ahnung habe kann ich es
fachlich nicht beurteilen aber es war
mir als laien doch durchaus verständlich
er hat so ein bisschen so die handlungs
theorie vorgestellt und es ebenso ein
bisschen abgearbeitet eben auch genau
diese frage wie verhält sich das
eigentlich mit den handlungen die wir im
spiel machen zu denen die wir der
realität machen also ergreift er eben
und ich glaube das ist auch eine frage
die für heute jetzt wichtig ist auf ich
zitiere mal ganz kurz wie verhalten sich
diese handlungen innerhalb eines spiels
zu den handlungen die man in ihrem
zusammenhang aus halb des spiels
übernimmt wie eben dem drücken von
tasten auf der tastatur kann man
überhaupt sagen dass beide arten von
handlungen in gleichem maße meine
handlungen sind und das ist ja auch ein
bisschen was was uns beschäftigt in
dieser frage was machen wir da
eigentlich ins spiel nun wieder solche
folterkammern bauern ist das eigentlich
unsere handlungen oder wenn wir wenn wir
irgend jemanden in irgendeinem spiel
töten ist es unsere handlungen ist es
die handlung von der spielfigur sind die
identisch sind die unterschiedlich und
all die fragen die das dann
schlussendlich auch auf wirft also mach
ich da was unethisches wenn ich eine
videospielfigur töte oder kann man das
überhaupt nicht sagen weil eigentlich
gar nicht alles real ist aber ist das
dann der handlung was ich mache und wenn
das keine handlung erst was ist es denn
dann bitte dann also da kommen ganz
viele solche fragen auf der uns da
beschäftigen können ja da hast du viele
punkte genannt jessica vielen dank da
kann ich gerade mein magen also der
handlungs begriff ist häufig definiert
auch durch intentional i tät intentional
i tät bedeutet so viel wie gerichtet
oder absichten ziele zwecke man muss
sich also immer überlegen im
computerspiel verfolge ich absichten
zwecke und wenn ja welche absichten und
zwecke verfolge ich und daran kann man
dann immer gut unterscheiden inwiefern
ist jetzt diese handlung die im
computerspiel vollziehe ähnlich zu der
handlung die ich außerhalb des
computerspiels vollziehe sicherlich habe
ich nicht die absicht am computerspiel
einen wirklichen menschen zu töten sind
ja keine wirklichen menschen aber einen
simulierten menschen vielleicht zu töten
und dann stellt sich die frage ist meine
handlung oder das töten diese
simulierten person ist das nur eine
simulierte handlung also ein simuliertes
töten der simulierten person oder ist es
ein wirkliches töten der simulierten
personen weil die person stirbt ja
wirklich im computerspielen also hier
geraten auch unsere begriffe die wir in
der realität anwenden so ein bisschen in
bewegung das verkompliziert die sache
und ich selbst habe auch keine
eindeutige antwort darauf wird nur sagen
es ist nicht trivial also hier können
kann die philosophie noch ganz viele
erkenntnisse erlangen nicht nur die
philosophie auch andere wissenschaften
natürlich psychologie soziologie
kulturwissenschaft sowieso game studies
sie auch neue forschungsbereiche ist
noch lange nicht wirkliche klarheit
darüber um was es sich behandlungen im
computerspiel eigentlich handeln und das
finde ich auch deswegen so interessant
war dass er auch gerne herangezogen wird
auch wenn es vielleicht um eine ich sage
das böse wort jetzt doch noch mal um die
killerspiel debatte geht aber auch um
ganz viele andere
themen die auftauchen wenn es darum geht
wir spielen später wird vollziehen
handlungen in spielen oder auch in
anderen formen wie wir mit digitalen
medien umgehen mit ki umgehen und so
weiter
und wenn dann das argument kommt na ja
aber wir machen das ja gar nicht
wirklich das klingt erstmal auf den
ersten eindruck irgendwie einleuchtend
weil natürlich wir laufen nicht in der
realität durch die gegend und schießen
lebende menschen ab aber wie du es
glaube ich auch gerade ganz gut auf
gemacht hast du es eben auch nicht so
trivial zu sagen na ja wir handeln da ja
nicht oder das sind keine echten
handlungen oder wie auch immer also es
ist das nächste trivial wie es aus
erster scheint und ich bin sehr gespannt
wo wir am ende unserer folge da landen
werden da kam ich gerade ein haken kurz
wenig darauf du hast auch einen guten
punkt gemacht jetzt mit dem töten der
person das verschärft sich ja dann noch
wenn ist zum beispiel sich dann im
internet spiele handelt also ich kann
jetzt die sims nur gegen computergegner
und ist ja kein gegner nur ginge
computer oder mit dem computer spielen
ich kann natürlich auch spiele gegen
andere menschen spiele im internet mit
quake 3 oder quake champions oder was
auch immer und dahinter verbergen sich
denn wirkliche menschen natürlich ihre
avatare aber da töte ich dann schon
etwas mehr die menschen natürlich nicht
wirklich aber ihre avatare hinter dem
menschen stehen als ich es jetzt wie bei
einem spiel täter wohl nur der computer
im hintergrund steht also auch hier wird
die sache ganz kompliziert je nachdem
wer sich hinter diesen anderen avataren
versteckt und mit künstliche intelligenz
die ja dann auch zusätzlich noch lernt
und in die auch menschliche daten
eingehen verkompliziert sich die sache
noch ganz entschieden
da können wir auf jeden fall ein
bisschen mehr unterscheiden nicht wahr
also wenn man einen
npc also ein nicht spieler einen
charakter sozusagen tötet in einem spiel
dann ist das nur so quasi terminiert man
da einen eine schleife im system ein
algorithmus die figur wird nicht mehr
dargestellt auf der anderen seite mit
anderen personen spielt dann hat das
wiederum auswirkungen auf die und auf
deren befinden und psyche die werden
natürlich nicht getötet ich habe keinen
also der akte nicht forciert er ist
sozusagen der den ich integrität
vollziehe aber er hat eine entsprechung
irgendwie und eine wirkung sozusagen auf
andere und kann so zu sagen ja auch
dahingehend noch mal irgendwie
diskutiert und besprochen werden ich
glaube diese beiden sachen müssen wir in
der weiteren und weiteren gespräch immer
noch mal so ein bisschen unterscheiden
aber ich würde fast sagen es ist noch
mal ein guter punkt ein kleines bisschen
ordnung in die begriffe zu bringen wir
haben jetzt sofort sehr viel über das
töten gesprochen und das ist etwas also
das haben wir uns jetzt auch nicht
ausgedacht unbedingt sondern das scheint
von ganz alleine zu passieren ist das
ein thema das sie immer ganz eng
verknüpft ist mit dem thema ethik und
moral also auch in den antworten die wir
bei twitter erhalten haben auf unsere
frage nach bösen taten haben wir ganz
überwiegend davon gehört dass dort also
virtuelle figuren getötet wurden wo der
vielleicht tiere und ähnliches
vielleicht noch mal die frage was sind
dann eigentlich in der philosophie tag
sozusagen ethik und ethische handlung
das ist ja nicht nur töten was ist damit
eigentlich alles gemeint über was für
arten von handlung sprechen wir dann
eigentlich das ist ein ganz wichtiger
punkt also die moralphilosophie oder
ethik das wird häufig synonym
verwendeten der philosophie
thematisiert handlungen erstmal unter
dem gesichtspunkt der absicht als man
kann handlung wie wir schon gesprochen
haben immer unterscheiden in die gründe
absichten und dann auch körperliche
bewegungen die zur durchführung der
handlung dann führen in der realität
hier ist dann je nach ethischen
paradigma je nach kritische grundhaltung
verschiedene es wichtig hier gibt es zum
beispiel die die ontologie die sollen
tätig die wird vor allem auf immanuel
kant zurückgeführt die sagt bei einer
handlung wenn wir sie bewerten wollen
moralisch kommt es nicht so drauf an was
am ende wirklich getan wurde in der welt
sind es kommt auf die gründe ankauf die
motivationen orientieren wir uns in
unserem handeln an dem kategorischen
imperativ geht es um die politik und das
motiv dann gibt es ganz andere e ticken
die man konsequenz iannis muss oder
utilitarismus nennt da kommt es nicht so
sehr auf die gründe an sondern auf die
nutzen erwägungen die damit einher gehen
also verbessert diese handlung die welt
egal jetzt unter umständen welche motive
dahinter standen also man sieht man kann
sich aus philosophischer perspektive bei
einer handlung auf den anfang auf die
gründe beziehen oder auf den output
gewissermaßen und dann gibt es noch eine
dritte position die tugend ethik die
fragt ist unser handeln so beschaffen
dass es einen gesunden mittelweg
zwischen extremen einschlägt ja also zum
beispiel die tapferkeit die liegt eben
in der mitte zwischen tollkühnheit und
feigheit hat das würde jetzt aristoteles
sagen also tapferkeit ist eine tugend er
spricht von der mitte der mesut s also
man sieht in der philosophie es ist auch
nicht ganz klar wie wir jetzt handlungen
ethisch oder moral philosophisch
bewerten es hängt immer davon ab welche
grundsatzposition wie gegenüber diese
handlung eine aber ganz allgemein kann
man eben doch sagen so moralisch oder
vielleicht sogar auch böse sind
handlungen die einer anderen person man
kann sich fragen ob es auch gegenüber
der natur oder gegenüber tieren nicht
menschlichen tieren oder gegenüber ja
warten jetzt ist die diesen gegenständen
diese person diesen gegenüber irgendwie
schaden zufügen und auf dieser schaden
kann ganz verschiedene art sein der kann
jetzt körperlich sein der schaden kann
aber natürlich auch psychisch sein
auch hier kann man wieder schön
unterscheiden also es hängt immer davon
ab welche gründe eine rolle spielen und
wie auch dann die folge dieser gründe in
der welt sich aus wild wie man jetzt
eine handlung moral philosophisch oder
ethisch bewertet
jetzt können wir jetzt wieder zum
beispiel zurück in die sims schauen und
wir haben jetzt leider selten in unseren
twitter antworten tatsächlich begründung
dafür bekommen aber ein paar kann man ja
sich so sage ich mal plausibel zusammen
fantasieren hier zb könnte ja ein grund
sein also dass man da sozusagen ein
szenario irgendwie durch spielt so eine
simulation so was wäre denn wenn das
jetzt irgendwie so passieren würde sein
als ob spiel das ist ja sozusagen auch
eine art des spielens irgendwie man sie
jetzt auch von kindern irgendwie kennt
da werden rollen spiele gemacht und dann
jemand ist die mutter jemand ist der
vater und genauso kann man sagen ich
spiele jetzt mal die rolle eines bösen
und guck mal was dann hier so passiert
ich denke es ist ganz wichtig dass man
in
computerspielen hier ist jetzt vor allem
die rede von simulationen für den sims
dass man hier verschiedene rollen
einnehmen kann also hier haben wir schon
von anfang an eine wahl was möchte ich
überhaupt für eine figur sein soll die
figur die ich jetzt hier spiele sollte
avatar soll die figur etwas mit mir
persönlich zutun haben möchte ich das
wirklich sein sollte sein abbild von mir
sein oder soll es nur eine ideal fit
muss sein also wäre ich gerne so wie
diese diese avatar fico also hier von
vornherein beginnen hier wichtige
entscheidungen beim computerspielen die
schon mit der wahl des avatars anfangen
dann kann man ja diese avatare bis ins
unendliche differenzieren bei neuesten
spielen ja also von der haarfarbe bis
zur größe es gibt so viele parameter die
ich da auswählen kann das bedeutet
dadurch einen ganz hohen grad von
individualisierung was gar nicht trivial
ist und den nächsten schritt wenn wir
uns dann den avatar geschaffen haben
besteht darin wie wir uns mit diesem
avatar natürlich verhalten im spiel in
dieser welt hier ist es die frage ist es
eine virtuelle welt oder nur eine
simulierte welt häufig wird simulation
und virtuelle realität synonym verwandt
ich bin der meinung muss dazwischen
unterscheiden er ist aber auch gar nicht
ganz einfach das zu tun also ich würde
jetzt erstmal spreche von einer
simulierten welt die aber dadurch dass
ich darin agiere durchaus liegewiese
relevanz bekommt für mich eine kausale
relevanz oder bedeutsamkeit und dann
würde ich von virtualität sprechen aber
auch diese unterscheidung ist noch
völlig unklar da gibt es noch keine
definitiven meinung in der philosophie
der 40 grad noch sehr viel und ich
möchte eben den punkt machen diese
ganzen und der scheidungen die kann man
besonders gut am beispiel des
computerspiels nachvollziehen auch
philosophisch konkretisieren deswegen
ist das computerspiel wie auch das
internet und andere phänomene ein ganz
wichtiger
untersuchungsgegenstand nicht nur jetzt
der gamestar de ist oder der soziologie
soll eben auch der philosophie und da
möchte ich dafür einfach argumentieren
dass noch viel ernster zu nehmen als nur
als ein bloßes konsum medium abzutun da
kann ich auch aus der sicht der
analytischen psychologie in dieselbe
kerbe schlagen auch da würden wir sagen
gerade bei rollenspielen wo wir uns eine
figur erschaffen die auf eine bestimmte
art vielleicht designt ist
schlussendlich allein dieser prozess und
ich glaube einige kennen das die
manchmal stunden damit verbringen bis
überhaupt mit dem spiel anfangen wobei
das natürlich in frage gestellt ist ob
man erst mit dem spiel anfängt wenn die
figur fertig ist oder das ja auch schon
zum spielen eigentlich gehört dass wir
uns genau mit dieser spielfigur die wir
dann sein wollen auseinandersetzen
wollen also ist das ein ich will wieder
gesagt hast ist es ein idealbild von
einer person die ich das schaffe ist
schon diese ganze prozess dieser
auseinandersetzung ein prozess ja
schlussendlich auch mit mir selber also
wer will ich eigentlich sein der will
ich nicht sein will ich vielleicht jetzt
mal in der rolle gehen in die ich im
realen leben nicht gehen würde also will
ich mich vielleicht auch mal ganz
bewusst jetzt mit in anführungszeichen
dem bösen identifizieren will ich
vielleicht wenn ich körperlich irgendwie
sehr klein bin will ich jetzt einen
riesen spielen oder oder das ist jetzt
so ein plattes beispiel aber das kann
man ja auch ganz viele ebenen übertragen
und deswegen glaube ich dass ja dieses
diese auseinandersetzung mit genau
diesen fragen auch zutiefst eine
psychologische frage ist und der frage
der persönlichkeit und
persönlichkeitsentwicklung da winke ich
jetzt auch noch mal an die katharina
mittelberg rüber die ich eigentlich auch
schon kanzler in diesem podcast einladen
möchte weil sie eine super spannende
dissertation zu dem thema geschrieben
hat persönlichkeitsentwicklung im
digitalen rollenspiel also irgendwann
wird das noch kommen aber ich glaube das
würde sie auch unterschreiben dass das
ganz wichtige auseinandersetzungen sind
wieder stattfinden
ich glaube ich muss nochmal eine
wichtige frage hier stellen und zwar
haben wir jetzt über avatare gesprochen
die wir uns selbst kreieren und es gibt
noch ein paar andere fälle mindestens
zwei den fall wo wir gar keinen avatar
haben wer sind wir dann im spiel sind
wir dann wir selbst oder was bedeutet
dass das ist das eine und jetzt achtung
ist kommt noch eine zweite frage
hinterher
was ist wenn wir eine vorgefertigte
figur vorfinden deren rolle wir
übernehmen sollen da würde ich einmal
den hexer geralt aus dem witcher
universum anführen das ist ja auch eine
rollenspiel reihe also das legt
eigentlich auch nahe dass man dort sich
selber hineinversetzen kann und durchaus
entscheidungen treffen kann
unterschiedlich handeln kann und darf
mit unterschiedlichen ausgängen auch
aber was ist das eigentlich für ein
unterschied wenn wir schon eine figur
präsentiert wird und vielleicht auch
schon gewisse werte mit dieser figur
verbunden sind
ich denke gibt es ganz verschiedene
fälle der
digitalen spielerischen
persönlichkeitsbildung jessica um auch
darauf wie darauf zu sprechen zu kommen
ich denke letztendlich ist es eine
graduelle phänomen weil
wir ja auch schon mit dem kauf des
spiels eine entscheidung trifft ja ich
würde sogar so weit gehen das spiel
fängt mit dem kauf des spiels oder mit
dem download des spiels an vielleicht
sogar auch mit der überlegung was könnte
ich spiel oder mit dem wille zu spielen
auch wenn das der spiel begriff wirklich
problematisch ist dann müssen wir auch
noch ein bisschen darüber reden was denn
überhaupt ein spiel ist weil da davon
hängt ganz entschieden davon ab also
wird sei es gehen so viele
entscheidungen einfach von vornherein
mit ein so dass wenn ich auch einen
vorgefertigten charakter habe ich immer
schon ganz viel entschieden haben bevor
ich ihn wählen und wir sehen eben auch
bei vorgefertigten charakteren häufig
gibt es eine auswahl welchen von fünf
charakteren möchte ich spielen ich denke
jetzt an diablo oder so oder wenn ich an
starcraft denke spiele ich diese spiele
ich die terraner spiele ich die protoss
also es gibt immer eine gewisse wahl und
viele spiele sind auch so verfasst dass
ihm unser handeln unser virtuelles
handelt sag ich jetzt mal computerspiel
zurückschlägt oder zurückführt auf
unseren charakter so dass ich bestimmte
eigenschaften entwickeln kann möchte ich
diesen skills erlernen oder lieber
diesen als auch hier findet immer eine
individualisierung stadt und ich glaube
mit jessica dass der erfolg und das
erfolgsrezept eines computerspiels immer
auch in diesem grad an
individualisierung liegt weil hier neue
möglichkeit zu räumen das ist für mich
ganz wichtig möglichkeitsraum und spiel
längst eng zusammen erschlossen werden
je mehr möglichkeiten uns ein spiel
erlaubt umso interessanter ist das spiel
für uns umso weniger trivial wird es ich
darf nur daran erinnern an diesen
übervater punkt wo ich jetzt nicht
entscheiden kann wohin spiele ich jetzt
den ball wenn ich das überhaupt
entscheiden kann von punk bis hin zu
modernen sandbox rollen spielen wo ich
fast alles
individualisieren kann da ist ein großer
weg den wir zurückgelegt haben aber ich
glaube dass das den trend der
computerspiele an zeigt immer mehr hin
zu einer individualisierung nicht nur
unseres aber teils auch der gesamten
spiele welt und auch der community in
der wir uns befinden
spiele als möglichkeit räume als räume
in denen ich verschiedene handlungen
wahrnehmen kann da sind wir auch wieder
beim handlungs begriff zurück
wobei sich die frage ja wieder
anschließt wenn wir in diese welten
gehen also ihr habt jetzt gesagt die
entscheidung geht schon ein bisschen
früher los also das ist jetzt kein
zufall dass sich dann eine figur
begegnet die vielleicht moralisch
interferenz ist oder eine strahlende
heldenfigur beispielsweise verkörpert da
geht die entscheidung los dann habe ich
eben ein avatar gewählt sozusagen unter
einer riesigen palette an spielangeboten
anstatt es im spielen mit zu
individualisieren und das ist sozusagen
auch schon 1 1
auswahlprozess woran ich noch denken
muss es auch die spielwelt denn
einerseits haben wir möglichkeiten aber
wir haben auch beschränkung auf der
anderen seite die können zum beispiel
mechanischer natur sein in einem shooter
kann ich vielleicht nur auf den abzug
drücken ich krieg gar keine möglichkeit
leuten die hand zu schütteln und mit
denen zu sprechen sondern ich habe
einfach nur ein abzugs knopf und auf der
anderen seite hat vielleicht auch die
welt wie sie mir erzählt wird narrativ
aspekte die mehr an ihr sozusagen
vermittelt werden beispielsweise eine
ein wertesystem in von der gesellschaft
in der ich mich im spiel befindet
welchen einfluss hat das eigentlich da
sprichst du auch wieder einen ganz
wichtigen punkt an endspiel und das
bringt mich ins zurück auf den spiel
begriffen spiel braucht immer regeln
also die bloße möglichkeit die ist noch
kein spiel aber da habe ich dann kein
gegen bezugspunkt an dem ich mich
überhaupt auch identifizieren und
definieren kann also spiele brauchen
immer regeln allgemein gesagt oder
begrenzungen eine welt die gewisse
widerstände welcher art auch immer mehr
entgegen setzt aber das interessante ist
im spiel spiele ich mit diesen
begrenzungen man sieht dass zb ein
phänomen des speed runs wenn ich
glitches verwende wenn ich also mit der
technik viele oder auch fehlende mit
fehlern im spiel spiele und sie selbst
zu interessanten gehalten machen oder
wenn ich irgendwelche anderen techniken
verwendet beispiel rocket jump oder
straif jumping das sind eigentlich
irgendwelche technischen vorgaben aber
im spiel entwickelt sich eine neue
kultur die damit kreativ umgeht und das
ist für mich das spannende dass man also
auch im spiel mit den regeln spielen
kann die die regeln sind nicht ganz in
stein gemeißelt sie sind verhandelbar
bis zum bestimmten grad und zwar nur
durch unsere kreativität und hier
beginnt für mich dann die virtuelle
realität wenn ich mit diesem medium auf
eine kreative neuartige kausal relevante
weise umgehen und das macht das
computerspiel zu einer faszinierenden
kultur wir sehen hier ganz verschiedene
entwicklungen ich habe schon ein speed
von dann verschiedene eigene spiele die
sich dann weiterentwickeln durch
modification zum beispiel das phänomen
des mobbing also man sieht ihr das spiel
wird eigentlich nie auf einmal gang
gesetzt wir spielen immer weiter und das
ist eben das was unsere kreativität
extrem reizt und fördert und wissen wie
computerspiele keineswegs trivial oder
auch nur irgendwelche konsum medien sind
sind hier werden wir wirklich sehr aktiv
nochmal kurz zurück fahren würdest du
auch also so erzählte regeln einer welt
auch als spielregeln irgendwo ein
stückweit begreifen wenn man sozusagen
in den magischen kreis des spiels hinein
tritt würde es diese geschichte zu den
regeln zählen eigentlich würde ich schon
tun du hast jetzt auch angesprochen
diesen nato- logischen aspekt es gibt ja
verschiedene ansichten von
computerspielen in diesem sehr
lesenswerten band der im juni us verlag
erschienen ist theorien des
computerspiels wird hier unterschieden
zwischen nato logischen ansetzen und
monologischen ansätzen ist ein
computerspiel er eine erzählung oder ist
es eher halt nur ein spiel wo beispiel
muss jetzt eben noch genauer bestimmt
werden ich würde schon sagen die nachher
tiefen strukturen bedeuten auch grenzen
oder definitionen des spiels über die
wir uns nur begrenzt hinwegsetzen können
wir können sie aber immer wieder
herausfordern wir können versuchen auch
einen eigenen weg einzuschlagen
gewissermaßen gegen die regeln des
spiels und das führt mich zu einem
weiteren punkt der vielleicht auch ein
bisschen was mit dem unmoralischen zu
tun hat nämlich dem chatten ja also wir
versuchen immer wir sind immer geneigt
auch diese regeln des spiels zu brechen
spielregeln zu brechen auch wenn sie nur
virtuelle oder simulierte spielregeln
sind und dass das natürlich häufig
sanktioniert wird sehen wir in
computerspielen wo es dann verschiedene
restriktionen gibt wo jemand gebannt
wird wenn er das tut also auch das
schießen ist ganz interessantes phänomen
wo es dann plötzlich wirklich beginnt
moralisch problematisch zu werden
jenseits der frage von klose simulierter
tötung oder sotschi ist doch schon was
viel ernsteres
ich muss während dieses gesprächs
tatsächlich und da bewegen wir uns noch
ein bisschen in diesem sogenannten nato-
logischen bereich an den autor und
spieleentwickler wolfgang balk denken
der unter anderem zb mal einen beitrag
für grimme game geschrieben hat die
ästhetik des politischen wo es um die
frage des des politischen in games geht
und dabei sagt er so zahn aus seiner
autoren und erzählerischen perspektive
etwas darüber so zu sagen was sozusagen
die dieser stellenwert von von
erzählten welten ein bisschen ist und
was so ein bisschen auch als aussage bei
wolfgang balk rüberkommt ist so die idee
das erzählte welten sozusagen eigene
regeln und auch eine eigene moral und
ethik mitbringen können und er würde
sagen die hat erst mal nichts mit
unserer echten welt zu tun ich kann mir
ein alien planeten ausdenken da gelten
ganz andere werte und regeln als bei uns
und dann hat das erstmal nicht zu
unserer welt zu tun wenn ich allerdings
sagen wir wir gehen jetzt mit dem gewehr
nach washington und ball an da ein
bisschen rum dann hat es ganz viel mit
unserer welt zu tun weil ich eben ja
diesen realen schauplatz habe und damit
auch sehr stark nahelege dass unsere
regeln und werte hier zu gelten haben
würdest du diese unterscheidung auch so
zustimmen oder was haben unsere werte
vielleicht auch mit fremden allen werten
zu tun erwählten zu tun das ist auch
wieder eine sehr spannende frage
sicherlich gibt es verschiedene welten
die unserer realen welt sage ich jetzt
mal ähnlichen ähnlicher sind man kann
zum beispiel auch an allegorische welten
denken wo eben bestimmte personen
verkörpert werden durch aliens oder
tiere usw also es ist damit noch nicht
eine andere welt gleich geschaffen wenn
die personen nur andere formen annehmen
es gibt kann auch das tut uhr analogien
geben wie eben in allegorien aber
sicherlich es gibt verschiedene
universen die wir auch durch die medien
kennen das star trek universum des star
wars universum also es gibt verschiedene
welten auch weltordnung die wir immer
wieder benutzen können um sie auch mit
unserer aktuellen will er eine
verbindung zu bringen das heißt wir
können immer auch die fiktionalen welt
aus welchem bereich sie auch immer sein
mögen mit unserer aktuellen bild in eine
beziehung setzen ich würde also
argumentieren wollen dass diese trennung
zwischen der fiktionalen welt und der
wirklichen welt jetzt anführungsstrichen
dass die so strikt gar nicht ist seine
die fiktionalen welten reflektieren
immer auf unsere wirklich bilden sie
stammt aus bestimmten zeiten wo
bestimmte politische themen vorher steht
werden und man waren und man kann eben
auch diese fiktionalen wählten sehr gut
gebrauchen um damit aussagen zu treffen
oder richtungen vorzugeben
die unsere wirkliche welt betreffen es
hängt auch hier wieder mit zusammen mit
dem kreativen umgang den wir haben zu
diesen fiktionalen welt aber natürlich
eine fiktionale welt ein alien universum
hat jetzt zunächst mal nichts mit der
welt zu tun die wir hier vorfinden aber
ganz davon verschieden ist eben auch
nicht mehr und in uns treffen diese welt
nähert dann doch wieder aufeinander das
ist ja auch das spannende finde ich das
dann auch in spielen passiert und da
will ich auch noch mal deine frage von
vorhin ein bisschen aufgreifen beiden
wurde sagt das was ist eigentlich und
was ist eigentlich los endspielen wie zb
witcher wo mir eine figur vorgegeben
wird die vielleicht in bestimmten
moralkodex
hat bestimmte werte und vorstellungen
die vielleicht auch sich von meinen
unterscheiden was mache ich denn damit
und mir ist es auch in witcher 3 ganz
oft so gegangen dass ich in situationen
war in denen ich mir dachte
ich habe die idee wie ich jetzt handeln
würde aber würde der gerald zu auch
handeln also wen will ich gerade spielen
will ich mich in den gehalt quasi
reinspielen oder will ich gerade
position einnehmen und merke mir gehts
haben manche stellt vielleicht nicht gut
damit was will ich eigentlich machen
also was motiviert mich jetzt überhaupt
welche art von handlungen zu begehen
will ich die wählen die mir am
ähnlichsten ist mit der ich mich am
wohlsten fühle will ich die nehmen die
vielleicht am interessantesten für mich
ist weil ich mir dann eine interessante
story line draus erwarte will ich die
handlung nehmen die mir vielleicht am
schluss die besten waffen und rüstungen
bringt das ist was was auch häufig
genannt wird wenn man fragt warum hast
du dich denn zum beispiel entschieden
auf die dunkle seite der macht zu treten
in anführungszeichen das dann solche
argumente kommen also auch da kann ich
auf ganz vielen verschiedenen ebenen
quasi mich entscheiden oder mich leiten
lassen in welche richtung ich mich
entscheiden möchte und da sagen wir
zusammen zu führen ich glaube in solchen
situationen da sind wir damit
konfrontiert und müssen uns in der
gewissen weise bewusst damit
auseinandersetzen also sowohl mit
unserer mit unseren eigenen
moralvorstellungen als auch mit denen
die mehr vom spiel sei es in form einer
nation in form von irgendwelchen regeln
strukturen was auch immer eben auferlegt
ist ich kann dir da ganz zustimmen
jessica im die regel im spiel sind nicht
nur regeln die uns gegenüber stehen sind
wir müssen es immer zu diesen regeln
verhalten und im verhältnis zu diesen
regeln da kommen wir selbst auch weiter
als es findet ihr immer so ein
wechselspiel stadt und das trägt am ende
dazu bei dass wir in einen
reflexionsprozess kommen und
verschiedene werte verschiedene rollen
hinterfragen und zwar im sandkasten
gewissermaßen im sandkasten der
simulation und das kann eben auch für
die wirkliche welt unseren alltag eine
bedeutung haben weil wir schon gewisse
optionen aus getestet haben uns darüber
klar bewusst wurden also es kann
durchaus eine art von transfer
stattfinden vom spiel von der sandkasten
box hin zur wirklichen welt deswegen bin
ich sehr der meinung dass man diese zwei
welten nicht so eine strikte opposition
stellen sollte sondern immer mehr
aufeinander beziehen sollte obwohl
natürlich die eine weltweit aus pauschal
wirksamer ist weitaus relevanter ist als
die spielewelt aber nichtsdestotrotz
gibt eine beziehung und diese beziehung
als solche ernst zu nehmen scheint mir
ganz wichtig zu sein wenn wir über
computerspiele reden
also ich habe das gefühl dass es
tatsächlich gar nicht so leicht den
finger auf dieses thema so richtig
zulegen wir um scheint das regelrecht zu
umschlingen wieso raubtiere eine eine
beute aber es ist schwer den sprung zu
machen man weiß gar nicht genau wohin
eigentlich
und ich habe aber das gefühl wir haben
hier so ein paar dinge schon daran
festgestellt die würde ich sozusagen nur
einmal gerne festhalten
für uns nämlich das eine ist dass es
irgendwie spiele gibt
medien gibt die bringen irgendwie ideen
und vorschläge zur moralischen
verständnis mit die haben vielleicht
eine welt und die haben figuren und die
bringen ethische ideen für ethische
werte mit und auf der anderen seite sind
wir wir bringen auch schon solche ideen
und vorstellungen mit aus unserer
erfahrung und das unserem leben und
unserer gesellschaft und wenn ich ein
jahr mit zu einem medium mit einem spiel
in kontakt komme dann kommen auch diese
unterschiedlichen vorstellungen
vielleicht ein bisschen in kontakt in
dialog in mir gerade gesagt
reflexionsprozess kann irgendwie dabei
angestoßen werden und so können dann
eben auch scheinbare welten die jetzt
erst mal nur ganz fiktional sind der
ferne planet
durchaus etwas in mir auslösen weil das
dann mit meinen werten irgendwie in
dialog tritt und was wir auch schon
gesagt haben meine werte können
vielleicht auch schon beeinflussen was
ich überhaupt auswähle für einen verein
spiel und jetzt habe ich das gefühl
dass jetzt der eine der sagt ich möchte
eine böse im figur beispielen und
irgendwie gucken wie sich das anfühlt
oder sowas oder das auch unbewusst
entscheiden vielleicht gar nicht bewusst
dass das eigentlich unterschiedliche
arten und weisen sind in diesen
reflexion modus zu gehen in diesen
austausch zwischen diesen
moralvorstellungen zu treten kann man
das vielleicht zu sagen ich finde es
eine sehr interessante idee und möchte
jetzt auch mal ein konkretes beispiel
bringen wo es moralisch wirklich ja
augenfällig ist dungeon keeper also
dungeon keeper 12 es gibt jetzt
verschiedene nachfolge spiele ich habe
noch den ersten teil gespielt dann auch
den zweiten hier muss man ja ganz
bewusst die rolle des bösen einnehmen ja
also ein dunkler kerkermeister
der dann die helden oder ritter die
eindringen in das dann sind die muss man
besiegt also die macht des guten und
hier finde ich besonders spannend dass
wir die kategorien zwischen gut und böse
im spiel reflektieren dass wir bewusst
mal die seite des bösen ob es überhaupt
gibt es ja die andere fragen hat das
böse wie man überhaupt von bösen redet
aber hier ist es gewissermaßen
personifiziert das böse durch
verschiedene kreaturen durchaus
irgendwie auch anschaulich gemacht das
war mal bewusst so eine position
einnimmt und mal die andere seite sieht
und das kann er kann eben wunderbar
medium des spiels machen das muss man
nicht in der wirklichen welt machen es
gibt eben leider viele menschen die
versuchen dass dann der wirklichen welt
zu tun solche beispiele gibt es auch
aber im spiel kann man eben ganz
verschiedene dinge tun die man sonst
nicht täten und bei dungeon keeper ist
das interessante dass das nicht todernst
ist revier ernst ist und dass das immer
ironisch durchsetzt das heißt hier
werden die begriffe des guten und bösen
selbst in einem jahr affleck tieren
ionisierenden bezug gebracht und ich
glaube das ist ganz wichtig auch für
unsere moralische bildung das ist ein
weiterer begriff die bildung ich glaube
tatsächlich dass wir uns durch
computerspiele bilden können dem wir
verschiedene begriffe man eine bewegung
bringen verschiedene positionen
reflektieren und auf eine art und weise
durch denken im raum des möglichen wie
wir es in der wirklichen welt die nicht
nur gespielt ist eben nicht tun können
das heißt dass es familien plädoyer für
die computerspiele aus einer bildungs
ethischen perspektive
ich muss natürlich dazu sagen es gibt
auch spiele die nicht diese
ironisierende funktion haben ich darf an
postal erinnern oder so es gibt durchaus
spiele die sind wirklich ethisch sehr
problematisch dass müssen muss man auch
benennen es gibt spiele die sind
infiziert
aus gründen die man wirklich
nachvollziehen kann weil man hier
irgendwelche ja wirklich verbrechen
simuliert und zwar nicht aus eine ironie
sieren weise sind aus einer ziemlich
primitiv und weise schon fast also hier
ich persönlich würde hier durchaus sagen
solche spiele muss man wirklich sehr
sehr problematisieren aus moralischen
gesichtspunkt dungeon keeper hingegen
hat immer noch diese reflexive dimension
dazu wo wir selbst auch in einem
moralischen bildungsprozess eintreten
können da würd mich interessieren was
denkst du wie kann man das unterscheiden
überhaupt also wann wo zu sagen also ich
woran kann man das festmachen und also
dass jetzt der dungeon keeper hat sagst
du dazu ein flexibles element hast du
erkennst und postal da erkennst du das
nicht wider wo andere vielleicht sagen
würde das ist er auch ironisch gemeint
natürlich woran wird es zu sagen kann
nichts am gegenstand festmachen also
bewusst ist sicherlich auch ein sehr
komplexes spiel es hat auch gewisse
ironische momente je nachdem welche
nummer man spielt nur scheint mir eben
dungeon keeper noch mehr funktional
gebrochen zu sein also hier steht mehr
fiktion noch drin und nicht nur die
simulation also je mehr fiktionale
elemente oder auch verfremden dem moment
ironisierende über zeichnende momente
ins spiel kommen da würde ich sagen ist
es moralisch nicht mehr so problematisch
wo sie gegen ganz detailgetreu ist wo
alle details minutiös nachbereitet
werden auch im sinne des tötens von
simulierten menschen wo auch bestimmte
grausame details verstärkt werden da
hätte ich durchaus moralische bedrängen
auch wenn es immer noch nur ein spiel
ist das muss man natürlich auch immer
dazu sagen getöten keinen wirklichen
menschen aber wo man sie die räte
realitätsgrad der simulations- grad
steht im vordergrund da würde ich aus
ethischer perspektive sagen hier wird es
problematisch je mehr wir uns hingegen
ironisierend reflexiv dazu verhalten
können im spiel da wird es wiederum
sogar moralisch sehr interessant weil
wir uns eben wie schon sagt in seinem
bildungsprozess hineinversetzen können
ich möchte ganz kurz wirkung einer
seiten fahrtstreifen aber den finde ich
in dem kontext einfach auch noch mal
sehr interessant und zwar ist das der
das ja auch menschen diese spiele machen
müssen und ich hab mal ich glaube es war
bei kotaku ich wird schauen dass wir das
in die chance packen habe ich einen sehr
interessanten artikel gelesen von einer
weile der sich eben damit beschäftigt
hat und was eigentlich mit den menschen
passiert die so wirklich auch sehr
gewaltvolle szenen animieren müssen also
wir müssen ja auch ihre ihre vorlagen
irgendwoher kriegen und was da eben in
diesem artikel drin stand und wenn ich
mich recht entsinne war das auch so ein
bisschen im interview charakter oder es
wurde auf jeden fall will welche
gesprochen ich weiß nicht mehr auf
direkte zitate drin waren jedenfalls
der grundtenor war eben auch der dass
menschen auch schon im prozess dass
machens eines solchen spiels
traumatisiert werden können weil sie
eben sich den ganzen tag damit
beschäftigen müssen wie menschen auf
grausamste weise irgendwie in stücke
gerissen werden oder sonst irgendwelche
makabren dinge an ihnen durchgeführt
werden und das muss natürlich auf also
das ist auch der anspruch wenn werden
wir dann schon in diese richtung kommen
es muss immer realer werden es muss
immer realistischer aussehen und so
haben wir auch erst in einer der
vergangenen folgen darüber gesprochen
denn das dann eben in diese richtung
geht wo sich dann die menschen die das
animieren müssen tatsächlich videos von
tötungen oder von schlachtungen von
tieren anschauen müssen den ganzen tag
dass das eben auch auf der ebene
vielleicht tatsächlich auch ethisch
problematisch ist nicht nur auf der
ebene der menschen die das konsumieren
sondern auch schon auf der ebene der
menschen die das machen müssen
da würde ich dir sehr zustimmen und hier
sieht man dass das computerspiel wo
solche details eine rolle spielen
irgendwie gar kein wirkliches spiel mehr
ist warum war hier fehlt diese distanz
und tier fehlt der möglichkeitsraum hier
geht es dann nur noch um möglichst
detailgetreue abbildung das hat
natürlich auch was mit spielen zu tun
aber hier wird im spiel auch ein ganz
eine ganz wichtige dimension genommen
nämlich der fiktionale aspekt hier geht
es eigentlich nur um simulationen von
grausamkeiten und hier wird eigentlich
des mediums spiel ja wie ich sagt eine
wichtige dimension beraubt und deswegen
glaube ich auch dass spiele dann
besonders interessant und anregend sind
wo sie nicht nur auf möglichst haargenau
simulation aus dann sind es simulatoren
das gibt es natürlich auch ein arma 3
oder so was glaube ich erinnern oder
irgendwelche u-boot simulatoren das ist
sicherlich spannend oder der neue
microsoft flight simulator oder so aber
da würde ich nicht wirklich sagen dass
ich meine persönlichkeit bilder oder
wirklich meine individualität einbringen
das ist eine simulation das ist
eigentlich kein computerspiel würde ich
jetzt sagen 700 simulatoren genauso gibt
es tötung simulator anja aber spiele
haben einfach noch viel mehr dimensionen
der reflexion der bildung wie ich sagen
möchte als es reine simulatoren haben
das was wir haben so das
bildungspotenzial auf der einen seite
darauf kommen wir vielleicht auch noch
mehr zu sprechen ich möchte aber noch
einmal auf diese andere diese kehrseite
eingehen die wir jetzt aufgebracht haben
neben durch dass dieser hohe
realitätsgrad
und nur die simulation und abbildung
unserer welt eigentlich da kommen wir in
gefilde wo du sagst das sehe ich jetzt
irgendwie sehr eng also je mehr wird
realität dass auch ist ästhetisch
relevanter wird das sozusagen für für
mein handeln dass du sagst das findest
du auch problematisch vielleicht dann
sogar in dem punkt was ist das das
problem dass du da sehen würdest wie
können wir das fassen also kann man
sagen da hat man vielleicht auch
bedenken dass es da ein zu starken
transfer gibt von von dem virtuellen
handeln in ein reales handeln oder in
die erzeugung von von werte bildern die
dem zugrunde liegen was würdest du dazu
sagen ist eine ganz wichtige frage ich
selbst bin kein psychologe aber aus eine
philosophische perspektive für dich eben
immer fragen was sind die gründe und
motive die dazu führen dass eine person
das eine oder das andere spiel spielt
oder auch wie sie es spielt aber noch
ganz wichtig es geht nicht nur um
welches spiel man spielten auch wie man
es spielt und wenn sich die person jetzt
für solche simulatoren entscheide die
eben besonders detailgetreue auch brutal
sind dann kann ich doch zu recht fragen
was sind die gründe die motive dieser
person das zu tun hier spielt sicherlich
gewalt abbau eine rolle dass wir uns die
sache der psychologinnen und psychologen
da kann ich nicht so viel dazu sagen die
gründen muss man müssen wir aber uns
betrachten und hier ist glaube ich ganz
wichtig zielt das darauf ab mit meiner
bisherigen wählt eine ersatzhandlung
alle auszuüben also in eine scheinwelt
mich zu flüchten die dann aber auch
kuriose weise wieder rückschlagen kann
in die wirkliche welt vielleicht durch
gewalt er hat das ding ist dass das ziel
das die motivation mich auch in
fantasien zu verlieren eine gegenwelt
aufzubauen die dann auch plötzlich
kollabo kollabieren kann oder geht es
mir darum ist der grund und die
motivation meine spielens etwas
auszuprobieren etwas zu erleben sich
auch anregen zu lassen
diese offenheit und diese offenheit
wieder thema bildung die sehe ich eben
nicht bei simulatoren so gegeben weil es
hier ziemlich zugeschnitten ist es
ziemlich verengt auf eine mögliche
abbildung der realität und da sehe ich
doch gewisse probleme aber am ende würde
ich immer fragen sind die motive die
gründe die eine person dazu führen diese
spiele die auf eine solche weise zu
spielen
ja die psychologische perspektive können
wir ja vielleicht kurz hier ergänzen
natürlich durch an ihrer ausführlichkeit
wie sind natürlich existiert aber wir
haben ja auch schon zwei folgen zum
thema aggression
aufgezeichnet da war der vorstand neu
man hier und da haben wir sozusagen
ersetzte theorie aber auch die
empirischen ergebnisse sozusagen uns
angeschaut was passiert eigentlich wenn
menschen sehr viel gewalthaltige spiele
konsumieren und dabei kam heraus dass es
auch tatsächlich kleine einflüsse auf
das tatsächliche verhalten dabei geben
kann unter gewissen voraussetzungen und
so weiter und so weiter das ist denke
ich die psychologische realität auch so
zu sagen da geht es dann nur hier um
tatsächlich einflüsse auf das verhalten
auch da würde ich auf jeden fall mal auf
diese folgen auch nochmal verweisen sich
die genauer anzuschauen oder anzuschauen
vielleicht ja nicht aber anzuhören
ihr dürft ihr gerne unsere bildchen dazu
betrachten nur nehmen wollt das ist das
eine aber auch was du sagst dass diese
gute motive zu hinterfragen ist auch
durchaus etwas das in der psychologie
passiert denn ein befund ist auch
beispielsweise das häufig eben nicht ein
gewaltiges spiel jetzt jemanden
produziert vorrangig der dann daher auf
die idee kommt gewalt handlung zu
begehen im echten leben sondern eben
genau auch andersherum wie du sagst dass
es personen gibt die haben schon gründe
diese medien aufzusuchen und die haben
vielleicht schon andere
[Musik]
persönlichkeitsmerkmale oder aspekte die
sie dazu bringen dieses auch auszuwählen
und da zeigt sich dann vielleicht ein
gewaltpotenzial einmal im auswahl des
spiels und einmal auch in handlungen der
realität beispielsweise das ist ein
effekt immer wieder gefunden wird gesagt
und vielleicht noch ein wort ergänzend
zu der katharsis hypothese wie sie im
fachjargon heißt
die ducati schon ein bisschen auf
gemacht hast york das ist etwas was man
auch sehr sehr häufig hört dass menschen
sagen ja ich schwer solche spiele um
mich abzureagieren und dann ist meine
aggressionen und peter nach weg das sind
tatsächlich anekdotische
befunde die immer wieder vorgebracht
werden mein wissensstand ist dass der
von der forschung so nicht gefunden wird
sondern dass diese ja kartause ist nicht
funktioniert also ich kann mich so ein
spiel spielen und danach habe ich keine
aggression mehr oder so sondern das
deckt sich eben mit den befunden die du
auch schon genannt hast wenn also dass
wir doch einen kleinen zusammenhang
zumindest irgendwie sehen können der ist
nicht so stark wie wir den seen würden
durch die persönlichkeitseigenschaften
durch bestimmte oder durch eine
bestimmte art von erziehung in der
kindheit da finden wir größere effekte
aber es ist nicht so leicht zu sagen ich
spiele das und dann ist meine aggression
weg also das ist vielleicht ein gefühl
ich kann mir das persönlich vorstellen
dass es daher kommt dass während des
spielens dann zum beispiel viel
adrenalin ausgeschüttet wird weil man in
stressigen situationen ist und danach
fährt man wenn man fertig mit dem
spielen ist auf dieser hormonellen
neurotransmitter ebene quasi wieder ein
stück weit runter und dann stellt sich
so ein gefühl von entspannung ein aber
das ist nicht das ich habe die
aggression jetzt abgebaut sondern ich
hatte gerade einen sehr hohen
adrenalinspiegel und der ist jetzt
runter gegangen und dann fühlt sich das
eher so an ja ansonsten gilt die kattas
hypothese weitgehend als widerlegt also
manchmal findet man da überhaupt keine
einflüsse manchmal gegenteilige effekte
dass das ausleben von aggressionen sogar
aggressionen weiter verstärken kann
exakt genau also das sind sozusagen er
die die richtung die man empirisch daran
fest stellt und dem zusammenhang würde
ich noch mal eben diese aussage auch in
spielen kommt ja niemand echt zu schaden
noch mal hier ja noch mal auf den tisch
bringen zur diskussion stellen kürzlich
gab es so ein artikel glaube ich zuerst
auf youtube.com mit dem titel männer
creating a fans and then we believe you
sing dann also die sich tag gezielt
ebenso
frauen an versprechen also weiblich
gefärbte ks würde ich dazu mal sagen
anlegen oder besorgen und die dann
irgendwie nur beleidigen oder
irgendwie anders missbräuchlich sich
gegenüber den verhalten und das ist ja
auch irgendwie so ein ja das finde ich
ist eine ähnliche vermischung wie beim
spiel wie wir darüber gesprochen über
das handeln sind jetzt diese personen
sind sie richtig handeln da als der der
sie sind oder spielen sie da irgend eine
virtuelle rolle irgendwie ein ganz
spannendes phänomen das erinnert mich an
horizon worlds wo es kürzlich in den
nachrichten zu lesen war dass dort am
avatare gespielt von echten menschen
eben belästigt wurden durchaus auf eine
sexuelle belästigung de art und weswegen
jetzt eingeschritten wurde und so eine
art sicherheitszone auch in diesem
virtuellen spiel um die avatare gelegt
wurde eine art virtuelle privatsphäre
installiert wurde und da sieht man als
anreisen world sieht man glaube ich sehr
gut das ist wirklich ethisch
problematisch diese personen haben sich
wirklich belässt gefühl durch andere
akteurinnen und akteure im virtuellen
raum jetzt den punkt den du erwähnt hat
das finde ich besonders spannend war
hier ist eine künstliche intelligenz ins
spiel kommt also da steckt jetzt kein
menschlicher aktuell keine akteurin
dahinter das heißt es endlich geht es
hier um einen selbst verhältnisse geht
es nicht nur im verhältnis zu anderen
personen mittelbar auch nur sei hier
geht es darum dass offensichtlich eine
person sich selbst etwas erschöpft um
dasjenige dann am ende auf eine sehr
unangenehme art zu adressieren und das
schlägt natürlich gleich auf die person
zurück das heißt hier kann man dann auch
wieder aus psychologischer sicht gut
fragen was für ein selbst verhältnisse
das selbstverständnis die diese person
zugrunde es ist sicherlich auch ein
experiment wenn man mit künstlicher
intelligenz auf seine weise verfährt um
mal zu schauen wie reagiert die
künstliche intelligenz eigentlich darauf
wenn ich sie so behandeln haben bei
künstliche intelligenz der unglaubliche
erstaunliche dimensionen aufweist die
wir die bisherigen medien so nicht
kannten war um weil die künstliche
intelligenz die lernt ja ständig dazu
und in die künstliche intelligenz
fließen ja auch menschliche leistung mit
1 man sieht dass sie auf ganz
verschiedenen ebenen das heißt ich
glaube künstliche intelligenz im
computerspiel wird noch mal besonders
moralisch politisch relevant weil es
hier eine mittelposition gibt zwischen
wirklichen menschen und losen
simulationen also künstlichen scans
extrem und der mitte angesiedelt und
dementsprechend auch ethische irgendwo
in der mitte also ganz spannendes thema
um es auf die frage einzugehen wie das
jetzt moralisch ist würde ich sagen
sicherlich künstliche intelligenz da tu
ich niemandem etwas an aber es ist
natürlich zurück schließen auf die
gründe und motive die diese person hat
und wenn wir jetzt mal sterne eine
kantige position drauf anwenden also
eine ideologische position die nach den
motiven und gründen fragt dann könnte
man so eine handlung durchaus auch
moralisch problematisch empfinden mit
guten gründen
genau da würde man jetzt wieder sagt
dass eben die die gründe und ziele der
handlung
hinterfragen und die sind irgendwie das
sind irgendwie schädliche absichten und
da würde man jetzt aus so einer
perspektive sagen schädliche absichten
das ist schlecht das ist wäre euch auch
unmoralisch auch wenn das jetzt dann gar
keine anderen menschen zunächst betrifft
wobei man ja fragen müssen wir uns ganz
genau sind nimmt kann es der schädliche
absicht sein wenn ich die ki selber
nicht schädigen kann also ich bin ganz
bei euch dass ich sage dass das
verhalten problematisch ist da das sehe
ich ganz genauso ich habe ihr sohn die
richtung gedacht na ja schade ich mir
aus schlussendlich selber dadurch nicht
im offensichtlichen weil ich habe den
artikel nur überflogen aber ich denke
die idee dahinter oder die motivation
ist auch da die hier naja dann lasse ich
das ja irgendwo aus ich habe eine
aggression und die muss ich jetzt
irgendwo auslassen jetzt lasse ich die
an die lkw aus dann geht es mir danach
besser und ich habe niemand anderem
geschadet und die frage ja eben auch
dann sind wir auch wieder bei dieser
katastrophe these funktioniert das denn
also geht es mir danach wirklich besser
vielleicht habe ich im ersten moment so
ein gefühl das geht mir danach besser
weil wie gesagt meine hypothese
vielleicht irgend wie adrenalin oder
whatever aber ist es langfristig gut für
mich also komme ich da nicht genau in
diese spirale rein ich brauche das immer
öfter die keine ahnung und die
beleidigungen müssen immer schlimmer
werden ich baue er eigentlich viel mehr
von dem aus weil ich natürlich wie eine
platte die ich oft abspiele genau diese
verhaltensweisen immer weiter über und
ein über und verstärke und auf
neuronalen ebene eben auch gedacht eben
auch diese verbindungen also unser
gehirn ist ja also hat eine plastizität
das heißt das kann sich verändern und
wenn dinge immer und immer wieder
gemacht werden dann werden diese
verbindungen zwischen den hirnarealen
oder zwischen den einzelnen neuronen die
dazu zuständig sind die werden dann
ausgebaut weil das gehirn quasi merck
kgaa das brauche ich öfter also sollte
ich hier ein bisschen mehr rein stecken
und dann schaue ich mir in letzter
instanz nämlich selber weil ich genau
dieses schädliche verhalten eben geübt
habe und dass immer öfter mache ja da
sprichst du euren wichtigen punkt an dem
ich den gesuchten also sucht wird sie
häufig auch mit computerspielen
verbindung gebracht das natürlich ein
riesenthema ein riesenfass was mir jetzt
gar nicht aufmachen müssen aber ich
denke es führt doch zum thema
medienkompetenz
mediennutzung und mediennutzung die art
und weise wie wir diese medien des
computerspiels gebrauchen die kann
durchaus aus moralischen gesichtspunkten
bewertet werden die ich
verantwortungsvoll mit den medien um
oder gehe ich unverantwortlich damit um
und das was du es beschrieben hast wäre
für mich ein fall von unverantwortlicher
mediennutzung warum weil es eben auf
mich zurück schlägt ich erreiche damit
nichts oder verfestige sogar meine
bisherigen
verhaltensweisen oder motive es heißt
meinte toni wäre aus dem ethischen
gesichtspunkte auch immer die frage zu
betrachten wie setze ich computerspiele
ein also nicht nur was mache ich in
computerspielen wenn ich mal trinken
sondern welchen situationen aus welchen
gründen überhaupt
möchte ich computerspiele spielen da
fängt für mich sogar die ethik des
computerspiels an also alles was vor dem
konkreten spiel vorgang schon liegt dass
er führt natürlich wieder auf die motive
ich mache keinen hehl daraus dass ich
ihr land da zu neige samson ethnologie
aber die frage nach der medienkompetenz
der mediennutzung scheint mir wirklich
ganz zentral zu sein und was wäre jetzt
eine gute form eine moralisch gute form
von medien nutzungen des welt was wäre
eine moralisch problematische oder böse
art von mediennutzung ich glaube eine
gute art wäre ihm eine nutzung der
medien die mich weiterbringt jetzt muss
man sich natürlich wieder fragen das
heißt sie zweiter bringen weiterbringen
würde heißen um beim vorletzten fall zu
bleiben dass ich mich neuen situationen
stellen dass ich also nicht immer wieder
dieselben dinge wiederholen in
eingefahrenen bahnen laufen sondern dass
ich mich herausfordern lasse durch das
spiel durch die regeln gewesen maßen
auch durch andere mitspielende person
oder avatar das wäre für mich
prinzipiell eine gute form der
mediennutzung und eine problematische
wäre eben eine solche die sich abkapselt
die sich auch nicht mehr wirklich
herausfordert die immer ihre eigenen
wege einschlägt gewissermaßen eine
zurückziehen in das medium eine
parallelwelt das wäre für mich eher
problematisch sicherlich jetzt nicht
böse zu nennen aber eine weise wie man
vielleicht nicht immer nur mit
computerspielen umgehen sollte
ja ich finde das auch noch mal sehr
spannend ich würde jetzt etwas
allgemeiner anteil dem größeren bereich
medien wir haben wir bei gesprochen
wieder etwas stärker zurück zu den
digitalen spielen kommen und da noch mal
die frage stellen wir haben ja gesagt
man kann sich da ausprobieren und hier
haben wir gerade über einen probieren
gesprochen was vielleicht an einem üben
ist von verhaltensweisen zu ungünstig
sind aber wir können allgemein überhaupt
mal etwas ausprobieren ohne dass es
sofort die konsequenzen hat eines
echten handels in
unserem alltag wir können dinge
ausprobieren die wir sonst nicht
ausprobieren können und dann auch selber
spüren wie sich das anfühlt und wir
haben auch gesagt das ist kann dann eben
auch zu seiner verhandlung und reflexion
von von werten beispielsweise kommen was
sind dann vielleicht beispiele wo du
sagst du hast schon dungeon keeper
mitgebracht hast du noch andere wo du
sagst hier dieses und jenes spiel finde
ich ermöglicht eine interessante
reflektion der verhandlung von ethik und
moral es gibt jede menge von spielen man
muss jetzt hier anfangen ist nur zu
unterscheiden welche perspektive ich in
dem spiel einnehme ist es eine dritte
person perspektive das ist ja meistens
bei dungeon keeper so ich kann da aber
auch einspringen in diese rolle dieser
arbeitenden wesen die darin diesen
dungeon graben das kann ich auch machen
und das macht dann schon gibt ja auch so
spannend dass ich innerhalb des spiels
verschiedene rollen oder perspektiven
einnehmen kann dann ist vor allem zu
denken an spiele wo ich eben der ersten
person bin wo ich in der ersten person
auch waffen habe die ich abfeuern kann
diese perspektive ist sicherlich die die
am realistisch ist also aus einer
ethischen perspektive würde ich sagen
sind diese perspektiven immer am
interessantesten vielleicht aber auch am
problematischsten wo ich eben auch seine
ich-perspektive das ganze spiel an
gewalt jetzt mit mir selbst in einer
verbindung zu bringen ist und nicht mehr
so viele zwischen medien dazwischen
stehen also wo ich nicht immer über die
schulter schauen sondern ich schaue aus
den augen raus ich bin eher es findet
eine gewisse deckung start mit diesem
avatar
dh mit dem krieg marien oder mit dem
dubaier damit wem auch immer oder in
wolfenstein es findet wirklich eine eine
wirklich nahtlose identifizierung
karlstadt und diese spiele scheinen mir
wie ich schon sagte aus moralischer
sicht besonders relevant zu sein hier
ist nämlich jetzt davon ab was ich
konkret crew in dem spiel auch wenn es
eine simulation ist ich habe häufig
waffen ich habe gegner vor mir willich
zivilisten töten in diesem spiel es gibt
in diesen spielen zivilisten oder will
ich nur monster töten auch hier wird mir
immer eine gewisse wahl gelassen und
weil es eben so realitätsgetreu aus der
ich perspektive ist sind auch diese
spiele wie mir scheint am
problematischsten damit will ich aber
nicht sagen dass alle ego-shooter durch
die bank moralisch verwerflich sind
keineswegs wir können nämlich auch aus
dieser perspektive und es immer noch
reflektieren das ist auch dann möglich
auch wenn es nicht mehr so leicht
möglich ist wie ihn spielen wo ich die
dritte person perspektive haben oder
sogar eine ganz andere perspektive
jetzt hast du erst mal sehr viel über
die perspektive also wirklich die
visuelle perspektive kann man sagen der
figur der mit der figur gesprochen und
jetzt gibt es ja aber auch noch ganz
viele andere
spielelemente die da irgendwie einfluss
nehmen können und werden uns am anfang
schon das will einfach noch mal auf auch
hier aufbringen einfache solche moral
systeme beispielsweise wo man dann
punkte für die böse handlung und punkte
für die gute handlung bekommt irgendwie
also schwarze punkte und weiße punkte
zum beispiel sammeln kann und daraus
leitet das spiel dann irgendwie eine
bewertung ab was hältst du dann von
solchen spielsystem das finde ich
wiederum sehr spannend weil hier die
moralischen kategorien von google böse
jetzt symbolisiert durch schwarz und
weiß kann man sich auch in anderen
hinsichten vorstellen weil es diese
kategorien reflektiert hier verhalte ich
mich aktiv zu diesen werten hier werde
ich nicht nur letztendlich ein bloßes
objekt der moral sind auch ein subjekte
moral also diese spielerische distanz zu
diesen werten finde ich aus
philosophischer aus moralischer sicht
sehr sehr spannend und hier kann ich
wirklich noch was ausprobieren hier kann
ich werte in ein verhältnis zu anderen
werten prämie kann ich auch mal schauen
wohin führt das wenn ich jetzt diesen
weg einschlagen und führte es wenn ich
den anderen weg einschlagen hier habe
ich immer noch eine gewisse reflexive
distanz zu diesen werten deswegen finde
ich solche spiele aus moralischer sicht
besonders spannend auch mit dem sinne
eines bildungsgang also wir kennen alle
diesen bildungsroman wo beschrieben wird
wie eine person häufig von kleinauf sich
entwickelt im laufe von jahrzehnten zu
einer bestimmten person wird ein
gewisser charakter wird gebildet das
kann ich im computerspiel auch tun und
zwar so dass mir die geschichte nicht
nur vorgesetzt wird gewisse regeln habe
ich vor geben aber da sich selbst zum
protagonisten werde und selbst mein
leben im virtuellen raum mal unter
bestimmten bedingungen leben auch
vielleicht auf hypothetische weise die
jetzt natürlich nicht gleich sich in der
wirklichkeit niederschlagen wird also
das finde ich moralisch sehr spannend
auch wenn ich jetzt in diesem spiel mal
hypothetisch oder nur aus interesse mal
die rolle der bösen macht einem das
bleibt auch immer noch in dem reflexiven
verhältnis zu diesen werten
und ich muss jetzt mal so eine
gegenposition einem also ich zumindest
aus spielerischer perspektive wirken
diese systeme immer so plump auf mich
also so ganz extrem vereinfachen so ein
hund töten gibt einen minuspunkt einen
menschen töten gibt zehn minuspunkte
vielleicht ist das ja auch dann in dem
sinne wie du sagst gut bei mir hat das
jetzt interessante reflexion angestoßen
aber ist es auch dann irgendwie ein
interessantes tragfähiges spielsystem
und ich denke mir das reduziert doch
meine verhaltensweisen so stark darauf
auf so einfache parameter oft ebenso
eine entscheidung im dialog baum wie das
eingangs genannte beispiel zünde ich da
diese atombombe oder nicht das ist ja
quasi nur ein knopf ja oder nein und
dann hat das irgendeine grössere
konsequenz einige konsequenzen kann
nicht absehen andere vielleicht nicht
dass es dann spielerisch interessant
unter umständen aber eigentlich ist
diese handlung selber ist so reduziert
auf auf einen schalter umzulegen oft das
ist so eine biotonne entscheidung gut
böse knopf 1 knopf 2 und dabei kamen wir
jetzt was er von möglichkeit räumen
gesprochen wir haben ja eigentlich ein
ganz grosse möglichkeit räume unter
umständen wenn wir an sandbox ist denken
wie minecraft oder sehr umfangreiche
rollenspiele wo wir ganz ganz viele
handlungsmöglichkeiten haben dinge zu
tun oder nicht zu tun
vielleicht kann ich in minen gehen und
rohstoffe ab sammeln oder pflanzen säen
und ernten zum beispiel so ich habe ein
großes handlungs report warnte es wird
gar nicht unbedingt ausgewertet
vielleicht vom spiel sondern das
interessiert sich dann nur dafür ob ich
dann irgendwo den knopf gedrückt habe
und das ist verärgert mich irgendwie so
ein bisher ich das gefühl weitergeht so
viel dann verloren und das spiel gibt da
gar keine rückmeldung über all die
anderen sachen die ich da getan habe da
stimme ich dir vollkommen zu sicherlich
gibt es auch spielt die begrenzten und
limitiert sind aber das heißt in meinen
augen nicht dass ich selbst mit diesen
begrenzungen wiederum spielen kann dh
eine möglichkeit jetzt darauf zu
reagieren du hast wie ich finde zu recht
da deine bedenken ausgedrückt angesichts
dieser beschränkung des möglichkeitsform
es wäre zum beispiel dieses spiel oder
seine logik oder seine beschränkungen
intern oder im moment zu umgehen indem
man zum beispiel schwächen des spiels
findet oder glitches oder so was die
dann plötzlich mich in eine neue
position zu diesen regelsätzen die mir
viel mehr freiheit ermöglicht also
hättest du dann würdest du nicht sagen
dass du in so einer situation gerne
versuchen würde es dieses spiel
auszutricksen um dir wieder mehr
möglichkeit raum zu holen gewissermaßen
ja darüber haben wir tatsächlich im
podcast auch schon mal gesprochen über
genau so ein verhalten die das wird
manchmal als out of bounds bezeichnet
wenn man sich in spielbereiche begibt wo
man eigentlich hin soll wo man der
spielregeln nichts zu suchen hat und das
ist aber gerade eben dann wieder zu
einem spiel geworden ist für viele das
zu erreichen wenn man sich speed runs
anschaut das wird jetzt zb alten ring
ereilen weil das die dark souls spiele
auch immer sehr beliebt waren und da
werden ja auch sehr sehr gerne glitches
ausgenutzt um dann eben zu sagen ich
erarbeite mir irgendwie neue wieder
möglichkeit räume wie du sagst zurück
und ich lass mich nicht beschränken hier
von dem spiel an dieser stelle sondern
ich widersetze mich ein stück weit den
den regeln genau das denke das zeigt
auch das computerspiel deswegen wird dem
schachspiel zum beispiel im schachspiel
bin ich wirklich angewiesen auf dieses
brett auf dieses feld was 3 und
physikalisch physisch mich beschränkt
was natürlich nicht heißt dass dieses
spiel unglaublich viele möglichkeiten
variation zulässt aber so was wie
glitches im schach gibt es einfach nicht
mehr und das deutet darauf hin dass wir
es bei computerspielen mit einem ganz
interessanten phänomen zu tun haben ich
stimmte aber auf deine frage das
sicherlich so eine schwarz weiß die
autonomie auch moralisch nicht
befriedigend ist weil die welt die
realität in der wir leben in der wir
nicht nur computer spielen die es nicht
nur schwarz oder weiß und dies grau die
can schattierungen das heißt da kann
sich doch zu recht in uns etwas regen
dass wir sagen also so einfach ist die
spielwelt nicht und die wirkliche welt
schon gar nicht ich möchte gerne in der
spielwelt mehr schattierungen haben dann
stimme ich dazu aber ich glaube die
neueste entwicklung der computerspiele
geht dahin dass die individualisierung
immer mehr an bedeutung gewinnen dass
man versucht diese schattierungen
möglichst gut ich sage jetzt nicht nur
zu simulieren soll vielleicht sogar zu
virtualisieren also wege findet das
anschaulich zu machen auf eine weise die
jetzt nicht in der eins zu eins
entsprechung hat zu unserer alltäglichen
lebenswelt und der verschieden von der
computerspiel welt also hier gibt es
ganz viele möglichkeiten und das macht
das computerspiel eben auch zu einem
hochinteressanten ästhetischen phänomen
wie kann ich bestimmte bedeutungen
symbolisieren wie kann ich sie in der
interaktion auch virtualisieren zu dass
eine bedeutung für mich erlangen die
nicht eins zu eins der bedeutung
entspricht wie wir sie in der wirklichen
welt in anführungsstrichen jetzt mal
finden ich finde dass entweder es auch
nochmal einem sehr interessanten punkt
angekommen weil wir haben es schon ein
paar mal gestreift habe ich würde
behaupten dass wir jetzt ziemlich dicht
dran sind nämlich genau an diese frage
wie gehen games denn damit um wenn wir
uns böse verhalten also da möchte ich
auch noch mal das stichwort der
prozeduralen rhetorik mit einwerfen dass
es ein konzept vom spiele forscher ihren
beau kos und es sagt im weitesten sinne
eben aus dass spiele uns durch ihre
handlungen beziehungsweise durch ihre
regeln schon ein jahr eine bestimmte
message vermitteln können also wenn ich
zum beispiel in einem spiel
ressourcen abbauen kann dann kann es
sein dass die ressourcen im spiel endlos
abzubauen sind dann sagt mir das spiel
quasi okay du hast hier ewig zur
verfügung während dem spiel aber eben
auch sagen kann hebers auf diese
ressourcen sind begrenzt und wenn du da
dein salzbergwerk in den berg reihenhaus
und das salz ist irgendwann aufgebraucht
dann hast du halt keins mehr dann musste
es irgendwo anders herkriegen oder muss
irgendeine andere möglichkeit bedenken
aber es ist nicht endlos das ist also
das was spieler uns vermitteln können
und das ist ja finde ich gerade im fall
auch von solchen ethischen oder nicht
ethischen verhaltensweise besucher
interessante frage also was gibt uns das
spiel denn als reaktion darauf wenn ich
zum beispiel die atombombe zünden in
sketchen skyrim in fallout 3 oder was
ist wenn ich in empire die leute aussage
oder die little sisters in bioshock und
so weiter was macht das spiel damit oder
in sims wenn nicht da mein falscher
kellerbauer krieg ich da werde ich in
irgendeiner form bestraft außer dass sie
sind irgendwie sterben dann nicht mehr
spielbar sind was macht das spiel damit
krieg ich zum beispiel in praia wenn ich
da böse bin dann kann es mir passieren
dass der boss sender am schluss absolut
auf dem maximal level ist weil ich kaum
eine chance haben ihn zu besiegen
während wenn ich nett bin mit sehr viel
einfachen endboss bekomme ist das eine
bestrafung kann ich das überhaupt noch
zuordnen dazu muss ich das spiel
eigentlich mehrfach gespielt haben um
das überhaupt zu wissen dass der boss
nicht so schwer ist am ende wenn ich
mich anders verhalten habe das sind
alles fragen die ja auch damit irgendwie
einhergehen
das ist ein guter punkt das spieldesign
ob das spielt diese eine das szenario
von vornherein schon so eine art von
message hat die mich vielleicht auch
moralisch beeinflussen möchte so kann
man sehen ich glaube aber dass man immer
egal wie ich im message oder intention
das spiel mit entsprechen wird natürlich
wieder von den gründen auch der spiele
designerinnen und designer auch
unabhängig von solchen möglichen
intentionen die man auch immer nur
schwer natürlich zu schreiben kann dass
das spiel immer neue möglichkeiten
bietet sofern es ein spiel es auch mit
diesen vermeintlichen vorgaben umzugehen
also hier können wir uns wieder sehr
kreativ dazu verhalten hier können wir
uns aus einer herausforderung wieder
neues spiel machen so ein metall spieler
und und wir hier können wir über das
guten böse diese unterscheidung immer
wieder weiter reflektieren sind ganz
neuen kontexten thematisch werden lassen
und das scheint für mich dann
letztendlich dann doch zweitrangig zu
sein was die spiele designerinnen und
designer vielleicht wollten oder wie sie
das spiel angelegt haben weil am ende
mache ich das spiel also nicht die ich
würde sagen nicht die designerin
designer machen das spiel sondern ich
mache das spiel ich entscheide welche
regeln spreche ich entscheide ob ich
schieß nutzen nur zu individualisieren
mir mein spiel sobald ich in der
spielwelt bin und das ist glaube ich ein
ganz großes bedürfnis nach autonomie
nach individueller auch
selbstverwirklichung sage jetzt mal in
anführungsstrichen auch in
computerspielen die noch so gute
designerinnen und designern absehen
können die können nie von vornherein
sagen wo wir am ende landen da würden
sie nämlich unsere kreativität
unterschätzen und wenn es ein spiel
zulässt dass man seine regel auch auf
die kreative weise umgehen kann dann ist
es gerade ein gutes spiel würde ich
sagen nicht nur im technischen
ästhetischen soll vielleicht auch im
moralischen sinne absolut wie ich bei
dir
ja da wo sie einmal direkt dazu ein hat
mich das sehr freut was du gerade gesagt
hast nämlich die rolle des dass der
spieler innen die du jetzt hervorgehoben
hast du sagst nicht die machen das spiel
sondern ich
mache das spiel hier wenn wenn ich mich
entscheide das hat irgendwie
teilzunehmen und das zu gestalten jetzt
muss ich ganz ausnahmsweise weil das
kommt glaube ich eigentlich nie vor aber
mal eigenwerbung machen für einen
beitrag den ich geschrieben habe vor
einigen jahren als sich an grimme
institut noch in der medienbildung
gearbeitet habe das grimme institut
beschäftigt sich ganz besonders mit dem
thema medien qualität und wir haben
damals einen beitrag geschrieben da
heißt zum qualitätsbegriff bei digitalen
spielen und den möchte ich an dieser
stelle einmal empfehlen und verlinken
denn ich habe genau dieses plädoyer auch
gemacht dass es ganz entscheidend ist
auch für die bewertung auch für diesen
qualitäts diskurs um digitale spiele zu
berücksichtigen was die spieler innen
machen mit diesen spielen also gerade
solche phänomene wie out of bounds über
die wir gesprochen haben mit dem
breaking the game sozusagen meta games
sagst du all diese aspekte und dass das
eigentlich auch ein dass das
interessante qualitätsmerkmale sind
spiele in denen sowas passiert die
vielleicht auch rahmenbedingungen
schaffen in denen sowas befördert wird
und passieren kann wo solche
auseinandersetzung aktions prozesse und
handlungs prozesse angestoßen werden
also all diese aspekte von peer
formation also ich nehme teil am spiel
ich gestaltet das spiel ich bin nicht
nur rezipient und ich habe auch eine
teilhabe ich kann das selber aktiv
gestalten das finde ich irgendwie ganz
ganz wichtig und da sind wir bei
vielleicht bei den dingen grad wieder
angekommen die games auch noch mal
auszeichnen können vor anderen medien
man könnte in diesem sinne sagen spiel
ist das was ich daraus mache und das
könnte man jetzt auch wieder auf unsere
frage zurückbringen moralisch gut
moralisch böse dem moralisch schlecht es
hängt immer davon ab was ich aus dem
spielmacher ist kann noch so moralisch
problematisch angelegt sein ich kann
mich immer dazu als spielerin als
spieler verhalten das heißt selbst in
einem potentiell unmoralischen szenario
kann ich immer noch aus freiheit aus
kreativer spielerinnen und spieler
freiheit mich dagegen oder dazu
verhalten das heißt ich würde ganz stark
appellieren an die autonomie der
spielerinnen des spielers im spiel und
die rahmenbedingungen nicht zu ernst zu
nehmen mein spiel ist immer
verhandelbares uns wäre es kein spiel
sonst wäre es ein korsett oder ein
gefängnis und selbst im gefängnis kann
ich noch spielen also das führt eben
wieder zurück auf die freiheit des
menschen und friedrich schiller sagte ja
diesen spruch kennt ja viele kennen ja
viele von uns der mensch ist nur da ganz
mensch wo er spielt so dem sinne nach
das heißt es ist irgendwas typisch
menschliche sich nie abzufinden mit
regeln oder mit vorgegebenen ordnungen
sondern der mensch tendiert immer dazu
die zu hinterfragen mit ihnen auf eine
weise umzugehen die jetzt auch nicht
immer gleich auf die wirklichkeit
ausgerichtet ist sondern erstmal auch im
hypothetischen im möglichkeitsraum zu
bleiben und das kann wie ich nochmal
plädieren möchte im sinne eines
bildungsraumes verstanden werden indem
wir uns auch moralisch natürlich
verbessern können
das ist ein schöner punkt den wir da auf
maß ich möchte noch einen kleinen aspekt
anfügen der mir jetzt gerade so gekommen
ist wo wir über diese dinge sprechen
doch der ist wieder mit einem
fachbegriff verbunden ich kenne ihn aus
der transaktionsanalyse ich weiß nicht
ob er auch in anderen
kontexten verwendet wird und wenn ja ob
er genau so verwendet wird nämlich der
sogenannte bezugsrahmen also auch jetzt
auch spielebezogene auch wenn mir ein
spiel zum beispiel wie jetzt in tampa
jahr sagt hey pass auf beziehungsweise
ich sagt ist mir ja nicht ich kriegst du
irgendwann mit wenn du jetzt hier böse
handels dann kriegst du am ende ganz
schweren boss und das ist jetzt eine
bestrafung dann kann ich aber immer noch
meinen bezugsrahmen ändern und sagen na
ja vielleicht ist es für mich ja gar
keine bestrafung sondern ich habe bock
auf einen schweren gegner
ich will nicht so einem langweiligen
bosse haben dem ich super schnell
besiegt habe ich möchte eine
herausforderung dann wird nämlich
plötzlich aus der intention die
vielleicht auch die entwickler und
entwicklerinnen hatten nämlich was ganz
anderes weil ich auch da wieder noch mal
auf einer anderen ebene eben auch wieder
was mit dem spiel mache und ich finde
das eine super interessante und so all
das wohl wir da gerade sprechen bin ich
super interessant eben auch weil wir ja
wissen dass uns auch einige entwickler
und entwicklerinnen zu hören also dass
auch das ein super wichtiger punkt ist
im spiele entwickeln immer zu bedenken
hater ist eine person und die person
möchte gestalten die person möchte
vielleicht auch das spiel an manchen
stellen breaken können möchte damit sich
in bezug setzen können auf ganz
verschiedene arten und vielleicht auch
ganz anders als ich das in tendiere und
plane das wäre sozusagen ein plädoyer
nicht nur im spiel zu spielen sind auch
mit dem spiel zu spielen dass ein mieter
spiel anzustrengen und das macht die
sache wirklich hochgradig faszinierend
nicht nur eben aus ästhetischer
gesichtspunkt 16 aus ganz verschiedenen
perspektiven
als letztes für heute möchte ich noch
mal den begriff des bösen aufgreifen wir
haben uns jetzt schon wieder ganz toll
gefightet hier sind wir ganz nah an den
grundsätzlichen fragen dran was ist ein
spiel was zeichnet es aus aber ich würde
uns sozusagen noch einmal auf sozusagen
diese diese banalität
das ist auch ein buchtitel nicht wahr
des bösen zurückführen denn auch du hast
ein buch darüber geschrieben das wollte
ich jetzt nicht unerwähnt lassen heute
theorien des bösen und du hast aber
heute auch gesagt gut und böse das ist
ja eine komische vereinfachung das
bildet ja gar nicht echte graustufen abt
in unserer welt existieren und dann jörg
ist die eingefallen aber ein buch zu
schreiben was der theorie des bösen ist
wie passt das zusammen was können wir
dann am bösen und an diesem begriff des
bösen dann noch ja du hast völlig recht
der begriff des bösen das
hochproblematisch nicht ohne grund
schreibe ich gleich im ersten satz warum
sollte man überhaupt ein buch über das
böse schreiben das böse ist doch das
unding dass um worte und begriffe die
man mit spitzen fingern am besten an
fast wenn es ihn denn überhaupt gibt ja
viele bestreiten ja auch dass es das
böse überhaupt gibt der begriff des böse
seien sehr provokativ normativer begriff
da müssen wir immer aufpassen wie wir
damit umgehen
dennoch habe ich gedacht das ist ein
faszinierender begriff damit muss man
sich auch mal aus philosophischer oder
noch mehr interdisziplinärer perspektive
befassen ich habe in diesem buch auch
nicht nur eine philosophische
perspektive darauf geworfen sind
ästhetische perspektiven psychologische
eine politische literatur und musik
wissenschaftliche perspektive das zeigt
einfach das phänomen des bösen zieht
sich durch unsere gesamte lebensrealität
durch unsere gesamte kultur geschichte
und durch und was ist jetzt das böse das
hängt natürlich immer auch von der
perspektive ab die man darauf wirft ich
habe versucht zu argumentieren das böse
ist jetzt nicht nur dunkle macht wie sie
häufig in computerspielen so vorkommt
sondern es böse hängt immer ganz eng mit
uns zusammen weswegen ich gar nicht so
gern von dem bösen spreche sondern
lieber nur von bösen sind eine
eigenschaft an der qualifikation und das
ist es von der eigenschaft es ist eine
eigenschaft die auf unsere freiheit
zurückzuführen ist und zwar auf unsere
individuelle freiheit also wir haben es
in der hand wie am ende sind ob unsere
handlung gut oder böse sind das ist
nichts was unserem schicksal unterlegt
sind das ist was was wir immer wieder
aufs neue unserer eigenen hand haben das
heißt in diesem buch habe ich eigentlich
nichts anderes versucht zu machen als zu
plädieren für einen starken
freiheitsbegriff autonomie individuelle
freiheit womit das böse am ende wenn man
jetzt von dem bösen sprechen möchte
zusammenhängt und weiterer punkt war
dass das böse betrifft es böse ist
häufig gar nicht so brutal oder so
mächtig oder so grollend oder so laut
sein böses vollzieht sich häufig ganz
unscheinbar so fast schon beiläufig
deswegen hannah arendt ja auch von der
banalität des bösen gesprochen habe das
fahren interessante wendung ich habe sie
noch auf eine besondere art und weise
interpretiert nämlich insofern als das
böse immer auch sich den anschein des
guten geben möchte also hier beim bösen
haben was immer auch mit täuschung und
mit schein zu tun nichts desto trotz
oder gerade deswegen ist das böse auch
aus rationaler sicht ein hoch
interessantes phänomen das böse ist
nicht nur ein defekt defizit ich mir
negation des guten von den bösen stück
immer eine energie die wir wenn wir uns
anstrengen eben auch zum guten hin
verwenden können das war das plädoyer
auch am ende des buches nutzen wir die
kraft die im bösen stück um sie zum
guten zu wenden vielleicht nicht
unmittelbar aber so doch von schritt für
schritt im kleinen das ist so der
ausblick alles böse ist auf jeden fall
hochgradig faszinierend und das denke
ich sieht man auch wenn man auf die
thematisierung des bösen im
computerspiel reflektiert genau das wäre
glaube ich meine letzte frage für heute
was schon gesagt spieler sind können so
zu sagen da auch bildungs vehikel sein
wir können uns daran bilden und wir
haben gehört viele probieren das böse
spielen mal aus dann kann das klappen
sich an böse spielen sozusagen noch zu
bilden und etwas daraus mit zu nennen im
digitalen spiele ich denke durchaus dass
es viel drehen kann weil das
computerspiel ja am ende auch immer ein
spiel mit uns selbst ist nah das möchte
ich auch noch so ein bisschen in die
debatte einbringen wir haben es hier
eigentlich nicht mit einem objekt zu tun
mit seinem gegenstand sondern wir haben
eigentlich immer ein selbst verhältnis
das wir herstellen im computerspiel das
heißt wir erfahren nicht nur irgendeine
computerspiel welt die uns vorgegeben
ist wieder hetero- nom sondern wir
erfahren uns selbst eigentlich auf
vielleicht auch eine ganz neue weise im
spiel das heißt wir können uns selbst
reflektieren hoppla was mache ich jetzt
das ist doch mal interessant soll ich
das mal ausprobieren so kenne ich mich
doch vielleicht gar nicht das heißt wir
haben immer die möglichkeit im
computerspiel auch zu einer art von
selbsterkenntnis zu kommen im idealfall
auch eine moralische selbsterkenntnis
und hier am ende dann doch zu einer
besserung zu führen das muss nicht sein
kann auch ins gegenteil ausschlagen
jedenfalls das computerspiel bietet uns
die möglichkeit und selbst auf eine neue
weise zu erfahren
und das scheint mir eben auch das
computerspiel aus der moralischen
perspektive sehr interessant zu machen
du sprichst mir aus der seele aber
sicher nicht nur mir sondern allen die
an diesem podcast beteiligt sind
mit diesem sommer vielen dank haben dich
ja knoll after all deiner interessanten
inputs heute und die anregenden
gesprächspunkte und da bleibt mir
eigentlich nur
zu sagen ich hoffe das selbe was
digitale spiele erreichen können in
ihren besten momenten
gilt auch heute für diesen podcast und
ihr seid sozusagen wird euch selbst
dabei interaktion getreten und habt
etwas in euch oder in der welt erkannt
und etwas neues gelernt oder vielleicht
ein bildungs prozess angestoßen das
würde uns auf jeden fall sehr sehr
freuen auf der einen seite wenn es euch
einfach gefallen hat und ihr gar nicht
in euch forschen wollt was da eigentlich
vor sich geht dann könnt ihr auch eure
aufmerksamkeit gerne ins außen berichten
zum beispiel auf spotify oder auf itunes
dort könnt ihr uns folgen dort könnt ihr
uns auch positive bewertung hinterlassen
das wünschen wir uns sehr das hilft uns
dort nämlich sichtbar zu bleiben und ihr
könnt uns auch über städte finanziell
unterstützen was dazu beiträgt dass wir
weiterhin solche teuren folgen wie diese
machen können dass wir uns zeit dafür
nehmen können solche tollen gäste
einzuladen und mit diesen worten auch
ein letztes wort antrag vielen vielen
dank dass du da warst und dann alle da
draußen bis zum nächsten mal ja vielen
dank auch für die einleitung von meiner
seite ich habe sehr viel gelernt und ich
möchte auch diesen diesen podcast weit
unterstützen wirklich ein sehr sehr
hörenswertes format vielen dank das
freut uns sehr danke
[Musik]